jacques benillouche bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france alors on l'a vue là
on a d'un côté un pays consignes et une
hausse des contaminations et puis de
l'autre une campagne vaccinale qui vu
d'ici en tout cas semble être une
réussite
alors qu'en est il réellement ce qu'il
en est réellement c'est que nous avons
deux communautés qui n'arrive pas à
accepter ce vaccin nous avons dû le para
communauté arabe et d'autre part à
communauté juive orthodoxe
alors la communauté arabe c'est pour
deux raisons je me suis fait piquer
samedi par une jeune étudiante en
médecine arabe et je vais poser la
question pourquoi les arabes ne veulent
pas les arabes israéliens ne veulent pas
participer aux vaccins et aux axes à
elles me disent qu'il ya deux raisons
d'une part il ya beaucoup de faits qui
use de me de mauvaises nouvelles qui
circulent disant que le vaccin des ddd
gay des conséquences secondaires assez
importante mais surtout elle me dit vous
savez chez nous on n'écoute pas la radio
la télévision et la radio israélienne
on écoute la radio arabe c'est-à-dire la
radio de nos voisins et kido nous donne
des informations très souvent erronées
entre autres les israéliens semble-t-il
dans ces radios veulent inoculer un
vaccin d'un poison aux haras tournée
éliminés donc à partir de là vous
comprenez alors de du côté des arabes
le gouvernement a pris des mesures il a
décidé d'augmenter le nombre de centres
il a décidé d'envoyer de beaucoup que
que des personnels médical arabe vous
savez que 30 % des médecins sont arabes
en israël
trente pour cent des pharmaciens leçons
et 50 % des infirmières sont arabes dont
il ya les moyens de venir dans ces
villages et celle est persuadé et de
l'autre côté vous avez une autre
communauté c'est la communauté juive
orthodoxe qui elle vit dans un monde
anachronique totalement isolé de tout le
reste
et elle ne veut pas entendre parler de
confinement pourquoi parce que elle l'a
des écoles dans lesquelles elle met les
élèves des élèves qui sont pris en main
depuis l'âge de 15 ans jusqu'à
leur majorité ce sont des gens qui
passent tout leur temps à étudier depuis
huit heures du matin jusqu'à minuit
il étudie les textes les textes
religieux
ils sont loin de d'avoir une formation
profane les maths la physique tout ça ça
les concerne pas et donc il est il est
pas laissée il est indispensable pour
l'est les rabbins orthodoxes d'empêcher
ces jeunes d'aller au contact je dirais
de la civilisation
donc il égare d'entre eux ils continuent
leurs cours avec tous les risques que
cela comporte
parce qu'il faut pas que les jeunes
sortent de leur giron il faut qu'ils
restent ans permet dans leur cadre et
donc nous avons des écoles avec 200
élèves et nous avons surtout c'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est ainsi nous avons
eu trois grand ravin qui sont morts
trois grands rabbins orthodoxes et à
chaque fois il ya eu des obsèques qui
ont rempli à peu près la rue avec 3000
4000 jeunes où effectivement orthodoxe
et quand on a quatre mille jeunes qui
circulent dans la ville sans masque et
sans contrôle eh bien on aboutit à ce
genre de problème donc ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que ces deux communautés
ont à l'heure actuelle le le plat plus
grande concentration de contaminer dans
les autres villes à tel aviv vous avez
des gens sont disciplinés ils mettent
les masses ils ne sortent pas en groupe
ils restent attachés à la sécurité
et c'est pour ça qu'il ya une certaine
mauvaise humeur chez nous en israël
parce que on dire par ce à cause de
certaines communautés
nous sommes tenus un confinement général
c'est comme ça que le concrètement mais
le confinement va être levé en principe
vendredi
on sait pas quelles seront les libertés
qui nous saurons de l'est mais on estime
que ce n'est pas normal que quelques-uns
quelques éléments dans la population
bloque la totalité de l'économie
israélienne
vous savez tout est fermé les magasins
sont fermés les cafés les restaurants et
il n'y a que les supermarchés qui
fonctionne et donc à partir de là la
population commence à être excédés
alors on a attendu l'objectif du
gouvernement vacciner 90% de la
population
cet objectif est ce qu'il est
atteignable
qu'il ya suffisamment de doses de
vaccins sur place est ce que c'est un
problème finalement quand on veut aller
se faire vacciner d'y aller il y a de la
place systématiquement comment ça se
passe oui alors je vais vous dire que
c'est très facile de se faire vacciner
vous téléphonez on vous donnait
rendez-vous dans beaucoup de cas vous ne
téléphonez pas ses lacets les assurances
sociales sécuritaire qui vous appelle en
vidéo monsieur vous devez passer vous
faire vacciner
c'est ce qui s'est passé pour moi on m'a
on m'a donné un rendez vous on m'a dit
samedi vous venez à telle heure à leurs
prêts si j'étais jeune est attendu que
trois minutes et après mon vaccin j'ai
attendu une demi-heure pour attendre les
effets secondaires éventuels donc à
l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas de
problème mais je vais même vous dire
plus le problème c'est qu'on a à l'heure
actuelle du mal à pouvoir faire les
vaccins à une époque on vaccine et 150
mille personnes par jour aujourd'hui on
arrive à peine 1 117 mais parce qu'il
n'y a pas de candidats au vaccin
les shows que des doses doivent être
jetés voilà c'est vrai et on a eu des
informations c'est qu'il ya eu à peu
près des milliers un millier de doses
par jour qui sont jetés à la poubelle
parce que lui il faut bien qu'on ne peut
pas garder ses doses en deux ans deux
d'un frigo de -17 points 70 degrés alors
ce qu'a trouvé
israël sait que maintenant vous avez des
grands centres entre autres devant la
mairie de la ville qui est une grande
place la place rabin eh bien on vous dit
à partir de 17h toute personne de plus
de 18 ans peut se présenter sans aucun
rendez-vous et être vaccinés donc ça
c'est assez pour montrer que à l'heure
actuelle on a du mal à pouvoir me
vacciner par manque de candidats c'est
quand même le comble c'est quand même le
coup quand on entend qu en france on
manque de vaccins et que dans l'est dans
certaines régions autour de nous pour ne
pas parler en cisjordanie eh bien ils
n'ont pas encore les vaccins qu'ils
veulent donc ça c'est un petit peu je
dirais le côté gâtés de la population
juive et la population israélienne qui
et je dirai même qui est un petit peu
gâté par rapport à tous les autres pays
aujourd'hui nous en sommes à trois
millions sans officiellement 3 millions
165 mille vacciner du premier tour du
premier vaccin
et à peu près un million huit cent vingt
cinq mille du deuxième vaccin
quand on connaît que quand on sait que
la population est de 9 millions et que
si on enlève les enfants et bien on
arrive à peu près à 4 millions quatre
millions cinq cent mille nécessaire le
nom normalement à être vaccinés ou et
qu'on arrive très vite aux résultats à
l'heure actuelle on essaie d'augmenter
en poussant par la publicité par les
informations poussant les jeunes
maintenant de plus de 18 ans à venir se
faire vacciner parce qu'il ya des
vaccins et on a le temps et les centres
comme moi j'étais samedi est bien et il
y avait très peu de monde et l on a on a
effectivement cette possibilité donc on
est sur la bonne voie en principe femmes
à nous aurons vacciner 70 % de la
population israélienne
ce qui est quand même un record mondial
merci beaucoup jacques benillouche
d'avoir été avec nous à ce matin je le
rappelle vous êtes un journaliste
indépendant et vous êtes à tel-aviv